هذا مثال صارخ على
جريمة حرب محتملة ارتكبتها القوات الروسية.
مثال لم يره العالم حتى الآن
جنود روس يطلقون النار على مدنيين اثنين
في الخلف.
حصل cnn على فيديو المراقبة
المأخوذ من تاجر السيارات هذا الذي
يقع على طول الطريق السريع الرئيسي
لتصوير الفيديو.  هو منذ بداية
الحرب حيث حاول الروس وفشلوا في
قصف طريقهم إلى العاصمة ، كان القتال
على طول هذا الطريق شرسًا بشكل واضح ،
لكن ما حدث خارج هذا العمل
لم يكن معركة بين جنود أو
حتى جنود ومدنيين مسلحين ، لقد كان
بردًا جبانًا  - قتل
رجال غير مسلحين على يد القوات الروسية بدم دماء
يظهر الجنود ويبدأون
في اقتحام كوخ حراسة يستعد رجلان أوكرانيان
لمقابلتهما.  آخر
تم التعاقد معه لحراسته
اسم والدي ليونيد أليكسيوفيتش بلاتز
ابنته يوليا أرادت أن
يعرف العالم اسمه وما هو روسي  الجواب
فعل له
كل من المدنيين العزل ، ونحن نعلم ذلك
لأن الفيديو يظهر لهم التحية
والتفتيش من قبل
الجنود الروس ، ثم يبتعدون بشكل عرضي
ويبدو أن أي منهما لم يشك في ما كان على
وشك الحدوث
وهذا ما تحدثه أحد أفراد القوة القتالية المدنية.
إلى الرجال
قبل يومين من الهجوم أخبر
CNN أنه لا يريد الكشف عن هويته
لأسباب أمنية ،
لقد جئنا إلى هناك في وقت سابق وحذرنا الناس من
مغادرة ذلك المكان ،
ونأمل أيضًا في إنسانية الجنود الروس ،
لكن للأسف ليس لديهم إنسانية
كما ترى  رجلان يمشيان في
الظل باتجاه الكاميرا
خلفهما الجنود الذين كانوا يتحدثون للتو
ليخرجوا بضع خطوات أخرى ويتساقط غبار
أجسادهم على الأرض
يتصاعد من الرصاص الذي
أصاب الرصيف ، وفتح الجنود
النار
بعد دقائق من وصول الحارس ليونيد
يعرج لكنه على قيد الحياة
تمكن من الدخول إلى كشك الحراسة
لإجراء مكالمة مع الرجال المحليين
للمساعدة ، هذا أحد هؤلاء الرجال
الأوكرانيين  سائق شاحنة تحول إلى جندي مدني
قبل كل شيء شعرنا بمسؤولية كبيرة
كنا نعلم أننا يجب أن نذهب إلى
هناك لأن رجلاً يحتاج إلى مساعدتنا
لأنه لا يزال على قيد الحياة
إنه قائد فريق من
المدنيين الذين حملوا السلاح للقتال من أجل
أوكرانيا و  حاول إنقاذ الرجال
عندما اتصل بهم الحارس ، وشرح ما
حدث مع الجنود وقال إن
الجنود سألوا من هم
وطلبوا السجائر ثم أطلقوا سراحهم قبل
إطلاق النار عليهم في الخلف
عندما وصل رجاله أخيرًا إلى
ليونيد فقد فقد الكثير.  كميات من الدم
ذهب رجل واحد من مجموعتنا إلى هناك
وكان الرجل لا يزال على قيد الحياة
وأعطاه ضمادات حاول إجراء
الإسعافات الأولية لكن الروس بدأوا في
إطلاق النار
وحاولوا الرد لكنهم لم
ينجحوا في
عدم امتلاك القوة النارية لإنقاذ
مواطنيهم  جوليا هل شاهدت
الفيديو الذي
لا يمكنني مشاهدته الآن
سأحفظه على السحابة
وأتركه لأحفادي وأولادي
الذين يجب أن يعرفوا عن هذه الجريمة وأن
يتذكروا دائمًا من هم  الجيران هم
جيرانها في الشمال ،
أظهر هؤلاء الجنود الروس مدى قسوة
شربهم لتحميص بعضهم البعض
ونهب المكان بعد دقائق من
قتل الرجلين ما هي الكلمات الأخيرة
التي تتذكرها التي قالها لك
قبلات قل مرحباً بأولادك وأولادها
سوف يتركون بذاكرة رهيبة تدوم
موت جدهم
الذي يجري التحقيق فيه الآن باعتباره جريمة حرب من قبل
المدعين العامين